بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين
اما بعد
نقول الله تعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا
اجتنبوا كثيرا من الظن ان بعض الظن اثم
قوله هنا
ان بعض الظن اثم
يعني مؤثم
اثم هنا بمعنى مؤثم يعني اسم المصدر
المصدر
اطلق واريد به اسم الفاعل وهذا يقع كثيرا
في القران
وفائدته المبالغه في الوصف
فهو يقول مثلا سبحانه وتعالى
يقول الذين يؤمنون بالغيب بالغيب ايش يعني
بالغيب يعني بما غاب عنهم
بما غاب عنه
من ما شانه ولا سبيل اليه الايمان التصديق
والتسليم
ولا سبيل الى معرفته الا عن طريق الوحي
فهذا سماه الله عز وجل غيب
هو في الحقيقه ما اريد به غائب ماشي
فاطلق المصدر واريد به اسم الفاعل مبالغه
نفس الاشي هنا اثم يعني مؤثم
يعني
سبحانه وتعالى
ان بعض الظن
مؤثم يؤثم من تلبس به يكون سببا في الاثم
والمعصيه والاثم
هو ما في اصل اللغه
اصل اللغه الاثم
يثبط عن الخير
اصل الاثم
والذي
يثبط صاحبه عن الخير
وفي الشرع
ما اكتسب وصاحبه محرما فاثم
واصبح ذا اثم
فقوله تعالى ان بعض الظن اثم يعني بعض
الظن يؤثم صاحبه
جرب الظن مجرد الاعتقاد مجرد
الظن هذا
فانه ياثم صاحبه
قد يسال
السائل فيقول
فما بال قول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
حيث يقول ان الله قد تجاوز لي عن امتي ما
حدثت بها
انفسها ما لم تعمل او تتكلم
قل هذا حديث صحيح
ولكن معناه الهواجس
والافكار التي تمر
مرورا في الخاطر
ولا يستطيع احدنا ان يسيطر عليها
هذه معفون عنها
معفون عنها
قد يمر في خاطر
ويلوح في خلدها
من اقبح الامور هذه هواجس من الشيطان
وهذه وساوس يلقيها الشيطان
والنفس تلقيها على الانسان
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اخبرنا ان الله
تعالى تجاوز له عن امته ما حدثت بها
انفسها ما لم تعمل او تتكلم العمل
قد يكون عمل الجوارح وقد يكون عمل القلب
القلب له عمل
التصديق
والثبوت واستقرار هذه الافكار
واقتناء هذه الافكار واكتسابها وان يعمل
بمقتضاها او يصدق بمقتضاها او يعتقد
بمقتضاها فان هذا هو الاثم
وان اعظم ما يؤجر عليه الانسان اعمال
القلب
قلبه
يتوكل على الله قلبه يخاف من الله قلبه
يشتاق الى الله قلبه الى اخره هذه من اعظم
اعمال القلوب
والعكس صحيح ان من اعمل اعظم السيئات
ضد ذلك العبوديه لغير الله سبحانه وتعالى
الخوف من غير الله التوكل على غير الله
الرجاء سوى الله
خشيت غير الله بما لا ينبغي الا لله
واعتقاد
الاعتقادات الباطله المنفيه
في الله سبحانه وتعالى وهلم جره فان بعض
الظن اثم يعني بعض هذه الاشياء التي تستقر
في القلوب هي بنفسها من الكبائر هي بنفسها
من الكبائر انه من الكبائر ان يتهم
المسلم اخاه وان من الكبائر وان عمله
الناس وان عم في الناس وان
يعني كان موجودا عند كل الناس كما على
عباره البعض فان هذا لا يغير حكمه هذا لا
يغير حكمه وانما يغير حكم الناس
يقول
تعالى ولا تجسسوا ولا يغتب بعضكم بعضا
الظن ان استقر في القلب ولم يسارع الى رده
المؤمن
ولم يسارع الى حسن الظن بنفسه فانها لا
تبرح
حتى
تؤتي ثمارها الوخيمه من هذه الثمرات
التجسس ومنها الغيبه
والله عز وجل ذكر التجسس
والتجسس هو
طباع
المساوئ والبحث عنها
تتبع الاخطاء
مهما كانت النيه
هذه
هي عقيده صهيونيه
التبس
التبست هذه العقيده على بعض المسلمين وعمت
ان
الغايات تبرر الوسائل نسمع هذا الغايات
تبرر الوسائل هذه ليست قاعده شرعيه
هذه قاعده صهيونيه شيطانيه
كان يعمل اي شيء المهم انه غايته صحيحه
على هذا
المعنى يسرق السارق ويتصدق قل انا بسرق
عشان اتصدق
وايضا يفعل الفواحش ويقول هذا لي منفعه
المسلمين والى اخره
هذا
ليس من اعتقاد المسلمين
ومن هذا التجسس
تجسس لا يجوز
لا يجوز التجسس وثم فرق
بين الضروره
وفرق بين
تقديم المصالح
ودرء المفاسد وما شابه ذلك مما يعلل به
نفسه نفسه صاحب التجسس كثير من الناس يفعل
هذه الاشياء
ويبررها لنفسه يقول صحيح التجسس حرام لكن
بالنسبه لفلان مش حرام او بالنسبه لهذا
المنصب مش حرام او بالنسبه الى هذا المكان
فمش حرام او بالنسبه الى هذا الزمان فمش
حرام هذا غير صحيح
هذا غير صحيح والعلماء ردوا على هذا وكثير
من الناس
حتى ممن
قد
يكون
من من له حظ بعض من لهم حظ في العلم
الشرعي الا انهم جرفتهم
كثير من هذه القواعد
والاصول التي اصلها الاصوليون ولم يفهموها
على وجهها
هذه الاشياء لا تكون
في مقابله النص لا تكونوا في مقابله النصر
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى اذا نص على تحريم
شيء فانه لا يجوز للانسان ان يقابل هذا
النص بالقياس ان يقابل هذا النص
بانواع من التعليلات
خلاص الله عز وجل يقول ولا تجسسوا خلاص ما
يتجسس
ولا
يغتب بعضكم بعضا خلاص ما يغتاب
وبعض الناس يذكر
هذه الاشياء لها استثناءات
والصحيح
ان هذه الاستثناءات
منها ما ليس صحيحا
ومنها ما ليس من الحكم اصلا
ليس من الحكم اصلا
وعلى كل حال الامثله على الامثله على ذلك
كثيره والذي يهمنا ان التجسس لا يجوز وما
هو التجسس
التجسس هو
ماخوذ من الجس والجس
ومثل الحس باليد
يقال جثه بيده
وحس بيده نفس المعنى لكن في فرق في المعنى
الحث يكون لظاهر الشيء
والجس يكون لي
وصف الشيء
فيقول العلماء مثلا
يقولون الحس
يكون من وجود الشيء
والجس
يكون
لماهيه الشيء
ايش يعني هذا الكلام
يعني خلينا نقول في كيس
كيس معلق
فانا امر عليه
واحط يدي على هذا الكيس
فهذا يسمى في لغه العرب حسن انا حسيت
الكيس
هذا الحث يكون ادراك الشيء بالحواس
فانا مسيت هذا الكيس
فهذا المس
يسمى حسن
فعلمت بوجود الكيس
فاذا انا مسكت الكيس وبدات
لافهم ما هو هذا الذي في الكيس
ايش هذا الشيء اللي جوا الكيس
فهذا الفعل يسمى جاسا هذا اسمه جس
يقول العلماء الحث
ادراك وجود الشيء
والجس
ادراك ماهيه الشيء
ماشي
لذلك
التحسس قد يجوز
قال
الله عز وجل حكايه عنه
يعقوب عليه السلام
اذهبوا
فتحسسوا من يوسف واخيه تحسسوا يعني
ابحثوا عن وجودهما
ولم يقل فتجسسوا
تجسس هذا امر اخر
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول
لا تجسسوا ولا تحسسوا
هذا الحديث في الصحيح
يقول لا تجسسوا
يعني تتجسسوا ولا تحسسوا يعني لا تتحسسوا
ولا يرتب بعضكم بعضا
ويقول ولا تدابروا
الى اخر الروايات كثيره فناهه عن التحسس
ونهى عن التجسس التحسس
واقل رتبه من التجسس
تجسس متابعه الاخطاء بدقه
هذا اشد تحريما من التحسس التحسس يكون
طلب وجود
هذه الاشياء
ماشي
فمثلا
التحسس
واقل رتبه من التجسس ويكون خطوه قبل
التجسس ماشي
التجسس هو المعرفه
الخفايا من الاخبار
والتحسس
معرفه ما قد يظهر من الخبر من الاخبار
ماشي
وهذه كلها محرمه ومن حق المسلم
على اخوانه
ان يكون مستورا الحال
من حق المسلم على اخوانه المسلمين
ان يكون
مستورا بسكر الله
ولا يحق لاحد ان يرفع هذا الستر
يقول الغزالي رحمه الله في احياء علوم
الدين قال حقيقه التجسس
رفع ستر الله عن من ستره الله
هذا حقيقه التجسس
كثير من الناس
ينظر الى هذه الاشياء ويقول
هذه احكام صحيحه
هذه احكام
لكنها احكام لا تنطبق على مثلي
حالتي او مثل هذه الحاله
تعلل باشياء
وهذا
سببه عدم تعظيم امر الله سبحانه وتعالى
اذا سال سائل
قال
ما هو
تعظيم امر الله
ايش يعني تعظيم الامر والنهي
هل كل من يقوم بالامر والنهي معظم له
السؤال ما هو تعظيم الامر والنهي
عظيم الامر والنهي بحثاه العلماء حقيقه
عظيم الامر والنهي
وخير ما رايت في ذلك تعريف الشيخ الاسلام
رحمه الله
وقد
نقله عنه ابن القيم في كتاب الوابل الصيد
قالت تعريف وتعظيم الامر والنهي
هو
الا يحمل او يعمل بهما
بتشديد غال
ولا
تفريط
ولا تفريط وترخيص
وان لا يحمل على عله توهن الانقياد
ايش هذا الكلام
قال الا يعمل بهما بتشديد قال
ولا يعرض
لتسهيل او لترخيص جاف
والا يحمل على عله توهن الانقيات انا طبعا
اذكر نص كلام العلماء وبنشوه ما في مشكله
يقول شيخ الاسلام كيف ما هو تعريف الامر
والنهي ما هو تعريف تعظيم الامر والنهي
تعريف الامر تعظيم الامر والنهي ما هو
نقول
انه هذا الامر الذي يريد ان اعتمر به
واريد ان اعظمه
لا اكون معظما لهذا الامر
حتى اكون عملت به
بدون ما اتشدد
حتى يصير
وغالي في هذا الشيء لان الغلو نافي لتعظيم
الامر والنهي
وبعدين ولا بحمل هذا الامر على ترخيص جاف
يعني ما بعمل فيه بهمله هذا برضو
من من
زعم تعظيم الامر والنهي وهو
مغالن في هذا الشيء او هو
مفرط فيه
فان هذا دعواه غير صحيحه
لكن القطعه الثالثه هي المهمه هنا
وهذا الذي
يكون كثيرا بين الناس
ولا يعرض
ولا يحمل على عله توهن الانقياد يعني انا
بقول صحيح هذا امر الله صحيح
لكن هذا الامر
لا يجب علي الوفاء به والقيام به
لان عله الامر كذا
سبب هيك وهذه العله لغيري مش الي او
لموقع اخر
طبعا التعليل الاوامر هذا شغل العلماء
ما هو شغل الناس
فمثلا واحد بده
بده
يغتاب غيره مثلا
واحد بده يغتاب ثاني
فماذا يصنع
اذا كان معظما لامر الله سبحانه وتعالى
فانه اول شيء ما بيكون مغالي فيها ولا
بيكون جافي عنه
المغالي فيه لدرجه انه بدخل في الغيبه ما
ليس غيبه اصلا
فصار الزلمه ما يغتاب لدرجه انه حتى
الكلام الحلو ما بحكي عن الناس
احنا مش غيبه
ولا بيمدح حدا ولا بحكي عن حدا لا بخير
ولا بشر خلص من مره ساكت
هذا غير معظم لامر الله لانه ما وقف على
حد الله الله عز وجل وضع حدا
الحد انك تذكر عن اخيك
ما
لا يريد ان يذكر عنه
ما لا يريد ان يذكر عنه ما يكره ان يذكر
عنه
فانت قلت لا هذا ما بكفي بدي ازيد عليه
هذا غير معظم للامر
صح ولا لا اذا المغالي في الامر غير معظم
له
كذلك الجافي عن الامر الذي لا يعمل به غير
معظم له
فعندنا واحد
ما بيذكر حدا لا بالخير ولا بالشر ولا في
الواجب ولا في شيء هذا غير معظم لانه
مغالب وعندنا الذي يذكر كل الناس الحلال
والحرام والطيب والخبيث كله يذكره ولسانه
يجري على طرفيه هذا غير معظم لانه متساهل
صح وجافي عن هذا الامر طيب
فهمنا طيب الثالث الثالث الذي يترخص
يقول الغيبه محرمه لانها تفسد بين الناس
لكن
هذه مصلحه او هذه
واجبه او هذه مهمه هذه اشياء لا تكون الا
في انذر النادر
الا في انذر النادر
يعني الذي
احدنا لو كان فعلا لازم يغتاب واحد مسلم
اخوه المسلم يذكر عنه شيء من الشر
فهذا ممكن يمر على الواحد مره في حياته
ممكن
ممكن مره مره واحده في حياته ولذلك
الصحابه كانوا يستفتون رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم في ذلك
ياتون اليه
ويذكرون غيرهم وهو يوجههم
هذه الانواع من الغيبه يعني مثلا تحذير
المسلمين تحذير المسلمين كل واحد بحبش
واحد ثاني بيقول لك انا بدي احذر المسلمين
منه لا بمشي المقصود
كل ما واحد زعلك بدك تروح تحذر المسلمين
يعني فاهمين القصه كيف
تحذير للمسلمين الذي يذكره
العلماء من استثناءات
الغيبه لانه مثلا واحد نصاب
حرامي
وواحد بده يتشارك معاه يدخل معه انك تحكي
بس لهذا الشخص بس وما تعتدي في الكلام
تحكي الضروره تقدر بقدرها
هذا هو المقصود قديش بصير هذا في حياتنا
مره في الحياه مرتين بجوز
ونفس الشيء مثلا تحذير المسلمين
يقول لك هذا شيء من الغيبه المباحه
يقول مثلا
المبتدع المبتدع الذي له بدعه فاننا ننصح
المسلمين ونحذر منه
ماشي لكن هذا يكون لمن
للعلماء
علمائهم الذين
يقيمون هذا الشيء
فهم الذين يقفون حيث
وقف القوم
ليس هذا لكل احد
وقد رايت هذا يعني
كان بين طلاب العلم
يعني الطلاب
كان احدهم يذكر اخاه طالب العلم باسوا
السوء
حتى يكون منه استهزاء وامتهان واستهزاء
بالاسم واشياء جاهليه
يفعلون هذا باسم انه على بدعه ليس هذا
كلام العلماء كلام العلماء
هو انه من كان مبتدعا يدعو الى بدعته
واصبحت خطيره على المسلمين لها ضوابط يعني
والعالم يقوم بهذا الشيء واذا قام عالم
بهذا فانها فرض كفايه مش لازم كل واحد
يحكي الى غير ذلك يعني لها ضوابط
واما القصه انه كل واحد يجعل شغله الشاغل
انه بس فلان وفلان وعلان وعلان سواء كان
ذلك باسم الاسلام او كان باسم
يعني شيء اخر فانه لا يجوز الاصل في
التحريم والاصل فيها الحذر
وامر منكر
ومخرب للمجتمع
ومهلك للقلب
وهذا امر يملا
صدر الانسان دخانا
واللسان
تكفره والجوارح كما ذكرنا في الحديث
على كل حال هذا ايضا ليس معظما هذا الذي
يترخص
ليس معظما
لامر الله وسياتي امثله على ذلك يعني مثلا
كل واحد يظن ان قصته
قصته هو خاصه
وانه قلمه هو الم خاص فريد ما في حدا
اتالم هذا الالم
وان النهي لا ينطبق على هذه الخاصيه
يعني مثلا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
وهذا يرى كثيرا
يقول
ايما امراه
طلبت الطلاق
من غير
ذي باس او بغير ذي باس لا
تشم رائحه الجنه بمعنى الحديث
يعني المرض باختصار الزوجه تطلب من زوجها
الطلاق من غير باس ايش يعني من غير باس من
غير
شده وهذه الشده شده شرعيه ليس يعني اي شده
ممكن الواحد يكون اي شيء لا الباس معرف في
القران والسنه يعرفه العلماء
فاي امراه تطلب الطلاق من غير هذا السبب
المبرر فانها لا ترح رائحه الجنه لا تشم
رائحه الجنه ماشي
لكن
كل وحده
بزعلها جوزها
حتى لو بتعرف الحديث وتقول لك هذا الحديث
لغيره مش الي انا اشوف كيف بسوي معاي هذا
هذا فلان بسوي وبسوي وبيسوي وبسوي كل واحد
بيفكر انه
الاحكام منطبقه على غيره وانا لا انا قصدي
فريده
مش فريده
هذا تماما
والذي يكون استثناء من الحكم هذا اشي نادر
جدا وبدك مفتي تستفديه في القصه
ليست المساله مساله انه
بيزعلني والله بفور دمي والله بطلع روحي
طيب ماشي بس
بجوز
الاسباب متبادله بجوز في اشياء اخرى
تستفتي فيها لكن انك تكون طيب ليش يا بنت
الحلال بتظلي تطالبي في الطلاق
لا ما هو اصلا طيب هيك الرسول بيكون ماني
عارف يا شيخ بس هذا غير لا مش غير
وبالضبط هذه النفسيه بالضبط بالضبط اللي
كان يتكلم عنها الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
واذا كل واحد اجاه الامر اعطاه لغيره مين
بده يعمل فيه جد يعني
اذا كل واحد اجى الامر اعطاه لغيره وقال
هذا الك مش الي
لمين مين بده يعمل في الامر هذا معناه
بيكون عنا احنا اوامر كثيره ولا واحد عامل
شيء
والى غير ذلك ان شاء الله سناتي بالامثله
على هذه القاعده وهي قاعده مهمه والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبي